my name is nicole ponseca and this is
miguel trinidad and we own jeepney and
maharlika and we're also the co-authors
of a new cookbook coming out i am a
filipino we're making our version of
lechon and then we're going to stir fry
it with pancett
you have more than 7 107 islands you
have to really consider the philippines
a disparate group of tribes and
indigenous people dialects so inherent
in there is food recipes value systems a
lot of people don't see where the meat
comes from although you can get
something similar by just using a cut of
pork like the pork belly this is the way
it's traditionally done you're using the
whole animal and nothing goes to waste
everything here can be eaten can be used
the bones you can save for a stock use
the leftover head to make pakishu pork
stew super delicious we did have a guy
from cebu which is known for the la
chong teach us the cebuano method i've
adapted it and added our own twist on it
manganese it is a sweet garlic cured
pork sausage now usually i trust this
with a needle but if you don't have a
needle all you want to do is take the
skin and pierce it so you can get the
string through it my food memories
always revolve around my father his
english wasn't the best and my tagalog
is non-existent so what we shared was
the language of food when he would feed
me
peanut stew or lachon i think it was a
way for him to transport me back to his
childhood so he could say you're a
filipino this is lachon the indicator of
the pig is done is going to be the skin
you know you want it crispy you can
knock on the skin this is usually cooked
over coals they skewer it with bamboo
and they turn it by hand just like when
you're cooking coals the skin is going
to get dark first it's a way of searing
the meat so all the juices stay inside
and it's nice and tender that way by the
time it's done that meat will just pull
off the bone we opened in 2012 during
hurricane sandy could not pay our rent
for about five months i had to think of
a way to get bodies into the restaurant
our goal with filipino food is how can i
turn anything that i was embarrassed
about into something of a source of
pride with kamaya night it came about
because i remember being embarrassed
about eating with my hands or my dad
eating with his hands when my american
friends would come i would even beg him
please order a pizza or a hamburger so
it makes sense to hold it with your
hands and i asked how can we turn this
around we wanted to make it grand we put
banana leaves on the table we burned the
leaves it became aromatic we tried
different landscapes of how to plate the
food because you eat with your eyes
first and then it just grew from there
in order to really understand the food
you need to understand the people so you
need to get involved you need to
understand the process because every
process is different for example me
going to culinary school you never burn
garlic but when you're cooking filipino
food you toast that garlic because
that's going to impart a completely
different flavor i wouldn't have known
that from reading any of the cookbooks
unless i actually cook with lola's
i would have never known that and these
are things when you're trying to cook
somebody else's food it's like really
understanding and cooking with them and
really jumping in there we're going to
use that jew for the pansit the
drippings from the longanisa the onions
the garlic the lemongrass
you'll see the remnants of the chinese
in our food panset for us it also
symbolizes long life so you'll have it
at birthdays you'll have it for marienda
which is our mid-afternoon snack have it
for lunch it's really easy to have any
time one of the obstacles for filipino
restaurants was when filipinos would
come to restaurants if it's not like
what they grew up on it's somehow not
credible but i think part of us being
out here is educating on the different
kinds of an adobo or recipes and just
broadening our spectrum of understanding
filipino food
[Music]
if food is one of the last vestiges of
identity can get really protected we're
not saying one is better than the other
but we're just saying there's so many
other ways to do it
oh yes
you